welcome to the David Pakman show I am of
course not David Pakman I'm Benjamin
Dixon host of the Benjamin Dixon show
podcast and YouTube channel you could
find me anywhere and you can find all of
my work at the Benjamin Dixon show calm
the David we'll be back next week I will
be with you for the rest of this week
let's jump into the chaos that was the
Cavanaugh hearings on yesterday
yesterday the Senate held their first
session in confirming confirming brick
Cavanaugh to become Donald Trump's pick
for the Supreme Court the next justice
on the Supreme Court and you know the
Democrats don't really have many options
on the table in terms of how they can
stop this guy who has clearly
demonstrated in his writings previously
that he is going to the Supreme Court
for one thing in particulars and that is
to overturn Roe vs. Wade but
subsequently there's also another thing
that he's potentially there for which is
to give cover to President Donald Trump
in the Muller probe and the
investigation so I want to take a look
at a couple of clips here that can give
you an idea of how yesterday played out
take a look at this first clip it's
confirmation hearing on the nomination
of Miss Brett Kavanaugh mr. chairman to
serve as associate justice mr. chairman
before we proceed mr. chairman I'd like
to be recognized to ask a question
before we proceed the committee received
just last night less than 15 hours ago
4,000 pages of documents that we have
not had an opportunity to review or read
or analyze we cannot be recognized I
move to adjourn
the American people Chairman I move to
adjourn directly
mr. Chairman I move to adjourn
and mr. chairman we have been denied we
have been denied real access to the
documents we need to advise Ehrman
regular orders cult which turns this
hearing into a charade and a mockery of
our norms well mr. chairman I therefore
move to adjourn this hearing and as you
can see the Democrats attempted to use a
technique to Monroe Lee reject this
hearing altogether to adjourn the
hearing you'll see later senator
Blumenthal attempted to actually get a
vote to to end the hearing but here is
Kamala Harris letting the record show
that they received 40,000 documents the
night before the hearing and a document
dump in order to get away with hiding
essentially hiding the majority of this
candidates of this nominees record
particularly at a critical time in
American history during the Iraq war and
on so many critical issues including
abortion and gay marriage LGBT rights in
general and so Kamala Harris is doing
her best to to resist in this way there
were protesters throughout the entire
event some were arrested most were
carried out and the the hearing devolved
into a bit of chaos but I want to play a
clip in particular of Senator Chris
Coons who calls out Cavanaugh directly
to his face and this is what he had to
say I want to pause for a moment on this
last point because the context of your
nomination troubles me the most in
reviewing your records judge you've
you've questioned the lawfulness of
United States v Nixon and historic
decision in which a unanimous court said
the President had to comply with a grand
jury subpoena you've questioned the
correctness of Morrison V Olson a
thirty-year-old precedent holding that
Congress can create an Independent
Counsel with the authority to
investigate the president who the
president can't just fire on a whim
you've questioned whether a president
and his age should be subject to any
civil or criminal investigations while
in office we have to confront an
uncomfortable but important question
about whether President Trump may have
selected you judge Kavanagh with an eye
towards protecting
himself so you know in terms of
confirmation hearings this is this is
quite dramatic he said it with a calm
face with the calm tone rather and but
he let it be known that he believes that
there's a possibility that he was picked
that Brett Kavanaugh was picked
specifically to provide judicial cover
for the President of the United States
to be able to weasel his way out of this
of the mullet investigation and this is
a serious serious accusation that that
really carries a significant amount of
implications if if Brett Kavanaugh is
nominated or rather if Brett Kavanaugh
is appointed he has demonstrated in his
writings he's demonstrated in previous
decisions and he's previous indicated
via gist commentary in general that he
believes in a stronger and even stronger
executive branch unitary President
presidential power to be able to really
stand above the law and this is the
exact type of person that Donald Trump
would need to get away with the things
that he's ruminating over that he wants
to do like a self pardon for example or
whether or not the president can be
indicted while he's in office Brett
Kavanaugh has unlearned it on the side
of absolutely not but there is even more
chaos when senator Blumenthal who
objected because they did not have
enough time to review the records that
were dumped of them the night before he
was trying to call for a vote to adjourn
the session and the chairman of the
committee absolutely refused to abide by
the rules of the committee take a listen
in here the Chairman is not above the
rules of the committee I asked for a
roll call vote to overturn the ruling of
the chair and to allow for a vote on my
motion to adjourn
he's proceedings that would be an
appropriate motion if we were in
executive business session but we're not
in anxiety business session so it's
denied mr. Chairman I will proceed under
protest we've had a lot of rhetoric so
far about
rules and norms I am very regretful that
the chair has adopted this stance which
in my view contradicts our basic norms
and rules but I will proceed we
absolutely have to understand that you
cannot be reasonable with unreasonable
people and in this case senator
Blumenthal is taken aback because of how
stone-faced and how you know with a
straight face chuck Grassley is telling
him that no you don't know the rules
these are the rules but senator
Blumenthal clearly has outlined the case
that Chuck Grassley is breaking the
institutional rules this is exactly what
it looks like when you have a person
who's trying to play by the rules going
up against a person who doesn't give two
cents about the rules I have to remember
I'm on david's program so I'm choosing
my words very carefully here but Chuck
Grassley doesn't care Chuck Grassley
doesn't care that he's breaking the
rules of the some of the Senate of that
committee he doesn't care that he's
doing it in front of the entire nation
he doesn't care that that he will
subsequently be found to have broken the
rules because there's no ramifications
for him he has nothing to lose his
singular job is to ram this through it
by any means necessary and this is the
asymmetrical fight that I talk about on
my program all the time you have
Democrats who if you look at senator
Blumenthal he clearly looks shocked I'm
not you're not anyone who's been paying
attention over the last 20 years is not
shocked that this is the tactic that the
Republicans are going to use right but
in the face of senator Blumenthal he
just cannot believe that chuck Grassley
is going to sit in front of the American
people when with a straight face lie
well that's what happens when you try to
abide by the rules and you're going up
against someone who doesn't care about
the rules whatsoever it's an
asymmetrical political battle and you
cannot win the Democrats cannot win in
this type of environment if they are not
willing to fight dirty just like the
Republicans are fighting dirty by all
means like if they can fight dirty to do
the wrong
things shouldn't the Democrats be
willing to fight just as just as dirty I
was going to try to fight another word
for it but just as intensely as the
Republicans to do the right thing